the things we're fighting will destroy
them all alike you can still help a lot
more than you've hardened Clegane it's
not too late for you
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video I will be
continuing with my character breakdowns
I plan on doing every character but
today I will be covering our favorite
Clegane which is Sandor Clegane aka The
Hound I think this is a favorite
character for a lot of people the hound
has had a very interesting character arc
in my opinion and I am really excited to
see the Hound continue to grow and
transform into a completely different
person than the one we first met in this
video I want to give my predictions for
some of the things that I think we can
see this character do in the final
season there is one thing I am really
looking forward to when it comes to the
Hound storyline next season well there
are several things I want to see the
Hound do but there is one reunion I am
dying to see out of all the characters
in this show one of my favorite duo's
was when the Hound and Oreo were
travelling together and these two will
finally meet again in season eight and I
think this will happen in the very first
episode Arya Stark is currently in
Winterfell in the Hound will be there
very soon we last saw the Hound in the
season 7 finale when everyone was at the
dragon pit but pretty much all of those
characters are heading back to
Winterfell to prepare for the war I
think Arya is going to be very surprised
to see that the Hound is still alive and
although she once had him on her list I
believe she will be happy to see him
again I can't wait to see the look on
the hounds face when he realizes what
type of badass Arya is now and I would
love to see these two fight side-by-side
against the army of the Dead I believe
John and Daenerys will arrive in
Winterfell in the first episode of
season 8 and the Hound should still be
in their party one of the main reasons
why I am really looking forward to the
Great War is because of all the
characters that we'll be fighting
together besides a few characters that
have sworn fealty to Cersei we will see
every other character in the north
fighting in the Hound will be one of
those people another thing that should
be interesting to see is how Brienne and
the hounds relationship grows from here
on out she's a knife iron
where Winterfell who's protecting out of
your here the only one that needs
protecting is the one that gets in your
way
they made the hound and Brienne reunited
right outside of the dragon pit and
neither of them seem to really have any
ill-will toward each other so I think we
could be seeing these two characters
fight side by side too and I think it
would be very interesting if the Hound
in Brienne ended up saving each other on
the battlefield they nearly killed each
other not too long ago but now the time
has passed and they know they are
working on the same team
I think the relationship can really
blossom in the future I think the Hound
does respect brianne's fighting ability
although she did kick his ass but I
think it would be cool if the Hound
saved her from being killed and that
would kind of let her know that there
was no bad blood between them and she
may even be glad he didn't die they may
not do something like this but I think
there is something there and I wouldn't
mind if they did that it could be very
similar to how the Hound and bran almost
fought but then bran saved the Hound on
the beach of Blackwater Bay it would be
a nice reminder that maybe they need
each other more than they think they
could get a lot more done if they all
work together and I think we will see
this kind of theme continue to play out
next season some of these characters may
have had bad blood in the past but now
they need each other and their only way
to wane as if they work together John
gave this exact speech when he was in
the cave with Daenerys and there was
another example of this when John and
his companions went beyond the wall
Poorman hated George dad Gendry hated
the Brotherhood and so on and so forth
but when they came together they
completed their mission I don't think
there is one person in Westeros who
loves the Hound as a person but Arya
eventually took him off her list in the
Hound and Brienne didn't come to blows
when they reunited
now that the army of the Dead is
knocking on their back door they will
soon find themselves depending on one
another to survive I believe the Hound
still has a purpose that has yet to
serve the Lord of Light is keeping him
alive and I am thinking he will step up
and do something big next season
Oh matters I believe is that there's
something greater than us and whatever
it is it's got plans for Sandor Clegane
I think the hound will end up saving
someone's life and we may even see him
throw himself into the fight to save
someone else Thoris of Mayor stepped in
front of the bear to save the hound
beyond the wall and I think the Hound
will repay that debt by doing that for
someone else next season but I don't
think he has to die in order to do this
Sandor could easily die in battle but I
actually think he will survive
everything I know that might be hard for
some people to believe because of the
type of warrior he is but the Hound
falls under the cripples bastards and
broken things category of characters and
those are the characters that I think
will make it until the bitter end they
were the characters who were laughed at
and given no love people were always
looking down on them because they never
thought they would really amount to much
but they are about to be the front line
of defense and they will be putting
their lives on the line to save the
entire realm the cripples bastards and
broken things will end up being the most
important characters in the whole series
in the Hound is one of those characters
in my opinion out of all the soldiers
who will be fighting in this war the
Hound is one of the very few all-stars
on this team the night King is going to
wish the Hound died beyond the wall
because the Hound is going to wreck shop
against the army of the Dead I know John
will gladly supply everyone with
dragonglass but I am also hoping the
Hound can use a Valyrian steel sword
during the war
you're not a good listener Valyrian
steel
I would wanted some Valyrian steel come
with me oh yeah this will be the first
time during the entire show that all of
the Valyrian still weapons will be in
the same place at the same time Arya
Stark will continue to use her Valyrian
steel dagger along with needle Brienne
of Tarth will continue to use her
Valyrian steel sword Oathkeeper but
there are a few other ones that can
possibly change hands during the battle
if Jon Snow ends up riding a dragon he
could let someone use his Valyrian steel
sword long haul John technically
wouldn't need that sword while riding on
a dragon in the sky and it would be cool
if he let someone else use the sword
while he wrote ragle and if he does I
think the Hound could use it until they
are done Samwell Tarly also has his
father's Valyrian steel sword hearts
pain and I believe Sam will spend most
of his time with Brian trying to figure
out how to stop the night king in
another way Sam could allow a much
better swordsman to use Hart's bane
until the nineteen is defeated that
sword would be a lot more effective if
it was in the hands of someone like the
Hound instead of Sam also Jamie
Lannister will be arriving with his new
Valyrian steel sword widow's wail this
sword was once given to Joffrey but now
that all of his sons are dead Jamie has
been the one to carry this sword let's
be honest though Jamie can barely hold a
sword these days and he knows this Jamie
already gave one Valyrian steel sword to
a much better fighter and I wouldn't be
surprised if he did that again so I
think there is a very good chance some
of these swords can get passed around
until the great war is over
and if that happens maybe the Hound is
able to use one for the time being I
think that would be pretty cold because
the Hound is one of the greatest
warriors they have on their team and he
is a lot more effective when he has a
sword in his hands than some dragonglass
weapon but that's just my opinion after
things get settled what the night king
there is still one more thing the Hound
needs to do before he can finally rest
before the series ends we need the
ultimate showdown between Sandor and
Gregor Clegane I know some people will
think this is fanservice if this happens
but I disagree I believe this was always
going to be a part of the Hound story he
needs to face his brother and kill him
for good
the mountain has been living on borrowed
time for years now but his Judgment Day
is coming next season
the hound even told him they're storing
the dragonpit seen what they do to you
doesn't matter it's not how it ends for
you brother
you know is coming for you you've always
known I believe this is their destiny
and there's gonna be one final fight to
settle the score I can't say this is the
only thing that has been motivating the
hound but he once told Arya that hate is
as good as anything to keep a person
going hates that's good a thing as any
to keep a person doing better than most
they come across my brother maybe we can
both cross a name off a list when the
Hound finally faces his brother one last
time he will deliver justice to all of
those people that the mountain has raped
and murdered over the past several
decades I think this old doll could have
a very interesting storyline next season
and I'm really looking forward to see
what they do with it there are a lot of
different directions they can take this
in but I believe he will reunite with
Arya and instead of fighting Brienne
they will work together and fight
alongside one another
I believe the Hound will survive the
great war against the night King because
they will have to take care of the army
of the dead as soon as possible and the
Hound can't die then because I need to
see him take down his brother Cain and
Abel style let me know some of the
things you think will happen what the
hell next season is there anything he
can do that I did not mention I would
like to hear what you have to say I want
to thank everyone for stopping by to
watch the video I really appreciate that
and I also want to thank all of my
patreon supporters I hope everyone has a
good day I will see you in the next one
but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]